Musik Ach, ich weiss nicht, ob das alles noch Sinn hat, hier dieser Podcast und alles.
Ich meine, irgendwie, du hast keinen Bock mehr, bei mir hängt es gerade auch echt durch,
wir finden die Termine immer nicht und dann können wir uns auf die Themen nicht einigen,
dann haben wir wieder Kommentare und dann mache ich Werbung für den Podcast
und dann mache ich die falsche Werbung für den Podcast und dann ist Stefan unzufrieden.
Ich glaube, das ist jetzt Folge 10, die machen wir jetzt, irgendwie machen wir die jetzt noch und dann ist es für mich auch aus, weil irgendwie so macht es keinen Sinn mehr. Hallo, hier ist der Stefan und ich begrüsse Sie ganz herzlich zum Podcast, an den weissen Florentin, der ist heute nicht gut drauf. Was hast du jetzt genau für ein Problem? Haben wir Themen auch oder machen wir einfach wieder irgendeinen Schwachsinn? Wir haben Themen, wir haben Themen, es ist Aufschieben und Zukunft. Ne, also Problem eins bist du irgendwie, also da will ich jetzt auch wirklich gleich direkt anfangen. Du bist echt der schlechteste Co-Moderator, den es gibt. Weißt du, ich bin
heute extra eine halbe Stunde früher
ins Studio gekommen, damit ich vielleicht
mal vor dir da bin, du warst schon da,
ich weiß nicht, ob du hier wohnst oder was das, was los ist,
du bist immer vor mir da,
du hast irgendwie breit grinsend
so eine Sushi-Box gegessen, habe ich gefragt,
kann ich auch einen haben, dann hast du
so getan, als würdest du kein Deutsch sprechen,
habe ich gesagt, Stefan, ich weiß, dass du Deutsch sprichst, wir machens. Und dann kamen nur noch ausländerfeindliche Witze von dir. Ich habe dir acht Mails geschickt, dass wir heute mal eine neue Rubrik ausprobieren, Sportkanal, wo wir uns ein bisschen über Sport unterhalten. Von dir kamen nur Gewaltvideos und Kinderpornos zurück, immer irgendwelche … Und Roboter-Fails. Roboter-Fails und wieder ausländerfeindliche Witze.. Ich weiß nicht, was dein Problem ist. Aber du musst zugeben, dass Roboter-Fails echt toll sind. Ja, Roboter-Fails sind schon ganz okay. Aber irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ob bei dir die Stimmung, also ob bei dir die Einstellung generell dem Projekt gegenüber noch die richtige ist. Du strengst dich nicht mehr an, wie du hast gesagt bei Folge 8, wir waren auf Platz 32, du strengst dich überhaupt nicht mehr an, deine Lorbeeren stapeln sich Kilometer hoch, ich weiß nicht, wo wo du da bist, ich weiss nicht, ob du unter deinem Zynismus überhaupt noch atmen kannst, den du dir da aufgebaut hast. Wir sind auf Platz 72 wieder, wir sind auf Platz 72 wieder, wollte ich nochmal sagen, das ist ein Erfolg. Vielleicht müssen wir diese Erfolge aber auch mal ein bisschen feiern, um dann vielleicht in Zukunft ein bisschen mehr Elan an die Sache zu gehen. Ja, wir können auch feiern von mir aus, also wenn du feiern willst, können wir auch feiern. Aber ich habe mir echt viele neue Rubrikideen überlegt, die hast du alle abgeschmettert, du hast alle gesagt, das ist scheiße. Sag mir mal die besten drei Ideen. Ich hatte Sportcenter, Tierzentrale und was ist eigentlich mit Heißluftballons los? So, das sind meine drei Rubriken, die hast du alle drei abgeschmettert. Dabei hatte ich mir wirklich Sportanalysen aus den Fingern gesaugt heute Morgen, da lecken sich Sky Sport die Finger danach. Ich habe alles analysiert, ich habe die Bundesliga analysiert, ich habe Snooker analysiert, ich habe überall das Letzte rausgeholt, ich habe Sportarten miteinander verglichen, ich habe Vergleiche gezogen, ich habe mir überlegt, wie würde dieser Sportler in einer anderen Sportart, wie würde er sich machen, ist das ein Transfer? Das ist eine ganz neue Art, über Sport zu denken, ist Sport nicht mehr in Disziplin einzeln unterteilt zu denken, sondern alles miteinander zu vermischen. Ja, auch nicht mal in Schubladen zu denken. Ja, auch mal raus aus dem Schubladen. Warum muss Basketball immer Körbe haben? Das ist eigentlich auch eine gute Herangehensweise. Kann man das nicht digital lösen oder so, wie so ein elektronisches Schlagzeug hat man dann nur noch irgendwie so ein Plättchen, wo dann irgendwie macht so Pfff, wenn der Ball draufkommt. Sowas zum Beispiel, kann man da nicht so einen Beat, kann man nicht einen Rhythmus machen. An welche Mailadresse hast du denn geschickt eigentlich die Ideen? Ich hab's. Vielleicht ist da das Problem. Ich hab holocaustlüge at stefan-titze.de. Ja, die hab ich nicht mehr. Wie, die hast du nicht mehr? Ich hab meine Meinung geändert. Gibt's stefanfantitze.de? Holocaust war keine Lüge, at stefantitze.de. stefantitze.de ist tatsächlich, so wie ich das sehe, schon besetzt. Ja. Homepage von Stefan Titze. Hallo, liebe Besucher. Ja, von einem Korrespondenten oder so. Schön, dass ihr auf meiner Webseite vorbeischaut. Sicherlich habt ihr bemerkt, dass dies nun ein neues Design hat. Ist mir tatsächlich gar nicht aufgefallen, muss ich sagen, das ging komplett an mir vorbei. Ich werde mich bewühnen, so schnell wie möglich die Website mit Leben zu füllen. Das sind auch so Sätze, die man immer ganz gerne liest, weil man genau weiß, die wird auch niemand lesen. Die Frage und Anregungen können die mich in der Folge. Hier ein schönes GIF. Ja, genau so Blog. Hey, mein erster Blog-Eintrag. Hey Leute, bald kommt der erste Blog-Eintrag. Freut euch schon, ich mache vielleicht was zum Thema Musik. Und wir sind zwei Gäste online, du und ich. Ja, ich hatte tatsächlich mal einen Blog. Ich bin transparent. Ich glaube, den Blog gibt es tatsächlich noch. Warte mal ganz kurz. Du hast einen Blog gehabt? Ich hatte mal einen Blog, ich kann ja mal tatsächlich einen Blog-Eintrag vorlesen, wenn ich ihn finde, ansonsten musst du jetzt erstmal. Wollen das die Hörer? Nein, bitte, mir ist kein Blog-Eintrag vor. Nein, aber dass man einfach mal. Wir wollen keinen Blog-rag. Nein, ich will auch keinen Blockertrag. Nee, die Hörer sind ... Was ist das für eine archetypische, klischeehafte Darstellung? Ich habe hier gerade eine Liste. Also, wir wollen nämlich über Aufschieben reden. Und wir haben uns ja da den ... Wollen wir es nicht in der nächsten Folge machen? Guter Gag. Guter Gag, ich bin der einzige, den du dir, zu dem Thema. Kriege ich jetzt immer einen Ping für so einen Gag oder was, weil ich gerade so ping gemacht habe. Warum kommen denn die Pings eigentlich? Ich kriege Nachrichten. Wenn ich jetzt auch lautlos stelle, höre ich die wahrscheinlich nicht mehr. Ich kriege auch manchmal Nachrichten, ich kriege also überhaupt kein Problem für mich. So, ich habe nämlich hier, hast du den Block gefunden eigentlich jetzt? Lass mich mal. Ich habe nämlich jetzt die Liste gefunden. Da stehen neun Gründe, warum Leute Dinge aufschieben. Ich finde, wir sollten die vorlesen. Oder nichts, oder nichts. Es beginnt mit Platz fünf und eins bis vier ist nur. Warte, warte, ich mache das eigentlich morgen. Fangen wir mit Platz fünf an. Fehlende Prioritäten. Das ist nämlich auch so ein Ding. Bei dir glaube ich nämlich, die sind andere Sachen, zum Beispiel deine YouTube-Karriere, viel wichtiger als dieses Podcast-UFO.
Obwohl wir hier natürlich, du mit deinem YouTube-Kanal,
sind wir ehrlich, du kannst das Feld
nicht mehr von hinten aufrollen. Da ist zu viel,
ich glaube, bei YouTube ist Hopfen und Malz verloren.
Da liegt zu viel im Argen, meinst du? Ja, glaube ich schon.
Und hier die Podcast-Industrie, die Deutsche,
wir haben es aus dem Stehgreif
auf Platz 30 oder so geschafft mit unserem Podcast.
Ich glaube, das ist eher so ein Feld,
wo wir von hinten aufrollen können und
das Ganze revolutionieren können.
Ich glaube, du solltest die Prioritäten anders setzen.
Geil, ich habe einen Blog gefunden.
Aber du hast völlig recht, ich bin momentan
eher auf meinem Blog konzentriert. Prioritäten
sind immer so ein Ding irgendwie. Prioritäten sind
bei mir nicht einfach Priorität eins.
Bei mir kommen Prioritäten auf
Priorität vier oder so. Davor ist erst mal
chillen, relaxen, Erfolg und so was.
Aber Prioritäten mache ich mir relativ selten Gedanken, weil ich bin so ein Typ, ich lebe aus dem Bauch heraus. Wenn ich was machen will, habe ich da Bock drauf, ist das wirklich meine Intention, fühle ich das? Das ist mir viel wichtiger als irgendwelche. Du bist ein spiritueller Typ eigentlich. Ich bin ein total spiritueller Typ. Ich lebe wirklich fast nur ausserhalb der materialen Welt. Das, was ihr so in meiner materiellen Welt fühlen und spüren könnt, das, was ihr auf materieller, akustischer Ebene, das ist vielleicht zwölf Prozent meines Wesens. Der Rest ist nur auf spiritueller Ebene. Was mir gerade an mir auffällt, ist, ich habe total das Klischee-Denken. Du hast gesagt, du bist ein spiritueller Typ und ich stelle mir dir vor, in so weissen Leinsachen barfuss durch die Wohnung laufend und mit so Fell an den Wänden, stelle ich mir dich gerade vor. Mit Fell an den Wänden? Weiß ich auch nicht warum. Mit Fell auf den Zähnen vielleicht. Fell auf den Zähnen und an den Wänden. Und dann läufst du immer, wenn du in die Wohnung reinkommst, dann schlenderst du, dann tänzelst du auch immer so ein bisschen und drehst dich und gehst an den Wänden lang. Das ist für mich das Klischee von Spiritualität. Und mein Gehirn funktioniert genauso. Ja, aber Aufschieben ist bei mir tatsächlich ein Riesenthema. Ich schiebe total gerne auf, ich liebe es aufzuschieben. Aufschieben ist das Schönste, was man machen kann. Wenn man wirklich so eine Aufgabe vor sich hat und dann so denkt, ja, könnte ich auch morgen machen und dann zack ist die Aufgabe plötzlich weg und dieses Gefühl der Erleichterung ist so schön, dass es jedes schlechte Gewissen einfach wegwäscht und damit bin ich da wirklich total teil drin. Wohl aufschieben, eigentlich was ganz was furchtbares ist natürlich. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, wo ich ich hatte mal in der Schule war ich bei so einem Projekt Schüler, lehren Schüler und da sollten Schüler jüngeren Schülern Nachhilfe geben und ich hatte Nachhilfe in Englisch und ich glaube, ich habe mich noch nie so sehr um eine Aufgabe gedrückt wie das, das waren glaube ich sechs Stunden und davon glaube ich habe ich eineinhalb gehalten, im Endeffekt und Und ansonsten immer, ja, Frau, so und so, ich habe heute Fahrschule und da hat man tatsächlich auch Geld dafür bekommen. Warst du der einzige Lehrer? Es ist schade, das wäre dich völlig aufgeschmissen. Oh nein, uns wurde Florentin wild zugeteilt und in drei Wochen ist der Test. Ja, komm, wir brauchen uns nicht. Keine Chance. Es gab noch andere und die mussten dann immer für mich einspringen und denen so, ja, dir ist aber schon klar, dass du da auch bezahlt dafür wirst und du musst es schon ein paar machen und ich halt sofort so, nee, ich will das Geld gar nicht und so und kein Problem und sofort wirklich, also in erbärmlichster Manier gebettelt, dass ich ja nicht meine Aufgaben erfüllen muss. Und das ist wirklich furchtbar, weißt du, du denkst dir, also wo ich mir zurückblickend auch mir nicht erklären kann, warum ich an diesem Projekt teilgenommen habe. Ich war faul, ich war schlecht in der Schule, ich habe mich nicht gerne in der Schule aufgehalten, ich habe mich am liebsten zu Hause in meinem Bett aufgehalten. Warum ich mich freiwillig dafür gemeldet habe, das zu tun, weiß ich nicht, aber es war die Hölle, weil man hat ja auch keine Autorität Kindern gegenüber. Null, also niemand. Also ich habe auch Angst, mich vor Kindern zu blamieren. Es ist auch sehr einfach, sich vor Kindern zu blamieren, weil Kinder haben ja generell keine Angst vor niemandem erstmal und auch keinen Respekt vor niemandem. Dem muss man sich erarbeiten bei Kindern. Ja, vor allem man hat auch nichts in der Hand. Das ist die schlimmste Situation. Als Nachhilfelehrer hast du wirklich ein riesiges Problem. Vor allem, wenn man schlecht ist in dem Fach, was man lernen soll. Dann ist es, glaube ich, generell schwierig. Aber der echte Lehrer kann ja irgendwie mit den Eltern reden oder Verweise und das ist aber der Nachhilfelehrer nichts. Den kriegen die Lehrer nie zu Gesicht, er kann nur seine Sache falsch machen, wenn die Kinder irgendwie die Prüfung verhauen und die Kinder haben einfach keinen Respekt vor dir. Du hast irgendwie Nachhilfe in der achten oder neunten Stunde, wo du selber einfach keinen Bock mehr hast und dann mitten im Unterricht holt irgendwie der Störenfried seinen Tischtennisschläger rauf und präht zu seinem Tischtennisball auf den Tischtennisschläger. Und bewirft dich mit dem Tischtennisschläger. Hallo, lass es mal so. Also war eine Katastrophe. Ich habe mal Nachhilfe freiwillig gegeben, damals weil es ein bisschen Geld gab dafür. Ich habe irgendwie zehn Euro die Stunde bekommen und dann habe ich eine Stunde pro Woche ein Mädchen unterrichtet. Da konnte ich aber auch nicht Nein sagen, weil sie mir Bekannte waren von uns. Und die hat viele Fünfe in Mathe geschrieben.
Mathe konnte ich eigentlich immer ganz okay und habe dann auch gedacht, ja komm, schaff das schon irgendwie.
Und dann war die erste Klausur eine Zwei von ihr.
Es war aber Geometrie und ich habe es natürlich nicht auf die Geometrie geschoben, weil es das einzige Fach, was sie konnte in Mathe,
sondern ich habe es auf die Milch geschoben, wie man es halt so macht.
Sie hat gesagt, du bist ein richtig guter Mathe-Nachhilfelehrer, weiter so.
Und habe das dann irgendwann mit richtig Elan gemacht, bis dann ein anderes Thema, ein anderes Themengebiet in Mathe drin kam bei ihr und dann hat sie fünf geschrieben und ist irgendwann so von einer vier auf ein Zeugnis auf eine fünf abgerutscht mit mir als Mathelehrer. Aber die Mutter war trotzdem irgendwie, weil sie halt bekannte waren, konnte sie auch nicht sagen, hör mal Stefan, lass es lieber, lass es lieber, sondern es war irgendwie so ein Zwangverhältnis, weil keiner von uns konnte Nein sagen. Und dann hat sie halt immer so gesagt, ja, gut, du bist vielleicht kein guter Mathelehrer, aber sie hat jetzt den Spaß an Mathe wiedergefunden. Und es wurde darauf dann geschoben. Das war ganz nett. Und danach kam eine, da bin ich dann umgezogen, dann kam eine Nachhilfelehrerin, eine neue, und dann hat sie zwei eingeschrieben jetzt immer. Also es lag offensichtlich an mir. Es ist auch immer abgedriftet irgendwie. Ich habe es irgendwie, die erste halbe Stunde habe ich noch versucht, irgendwie über Mathe noch zu reden und irgendwann fand ich es viel interessanter, wenn sie... Hast du nur noch mit ihr rumgemacht. Genau, nur mit ihr rumgemacht. Und ich fand die Geschichten, die sie aus der Schule erzählt, einfach viel interessanter. Naja. Ich habe dir gerade einen Link geschickt von meinem Blog, also falls dich mal ein bisschen inspirieren, wo ich das... Wo denn eigentlich? Über Skype, falls dich mal ein bisschen inspirieren, weil wir gucken ja halt natürlich auch in die Zukunft. Thema ist Zukunft, wie geht es in der nächsten Zeit weiter, wie leben wir in fünf, in zehn Jahren, wie sieht die Medienwelt aus, wie sieht die echte Welt aus, was passiert und da ist, wo wir in den Blogs. Ganz kurz, ich bin ein richtiger Skype-Noop und ich weiss gerade nicht, wo ich diese Nachricht finden soll. Oder Kontakte. Oder Kontakte und dann auf mich und dann im Chatfenster.
Pornowerbung. Es gibt die schwierigste Aufgabe, die jeder Moderator einmal machen sollte, ist, Stefan Titzes Lücken zu wegmoderieren, weil die sind so lange und so zäh, dass man das überhaupt nicht kann. Also wenn Stefan Titzel mal irgendwie was recherchieren soll, man währenddessen irgendwas moderieren soll. Und was auch so eine Riesenaufgabe ist, dass dann der zweite Teil eurer Moderation, auf dem Weg
zum Olymp der Moderation,
ist dann mit Florentin Wild zu arbeiten, weil das ist ein Riesenarschloch.
Er macht euch in jedem zweiten Satz, macht euch fertig,
fängt Folgen an,
indem er die Laune einfach so von
100 einfach auf 0 runterdrückt
und anfängt zu sagen, ja, uns gibt's bald nicht mehr.
Das ist auch dann der nächste Schritt.
Wenn ihr das überstanden habt, diese beiden Stufen, dann seid ihr wirklich ein Supermoderator.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ja, schöner Blog. Sieht auch toll aus.
Auch das Design gefällt mir außerordentlich gut.
Es ist echt, warum eigentlich
ein Nifty-Blog?
Ja, gute Frage. Nifty,
so hieß meine Katze früher und so habe ich mich dann auch genannt
und das war so mein
Handel, so Nifty, das war so mein Ding. Möchtest du mal was vorlesen? Liesst du doch mal was vor, was dir am besten gefällt. Sechs Anzeichen dafür, dass dein Biorhythmus vollkommen ruiniert ist. Hallo Welt, alles so passiert. Haha, Zwinkelzwinkel. Erstens, du kannst nicht mehr einschlafen, ohne das Frühstücksfernsehen gesehen zu haben. Kannst du bitte jede Zeile mit einer Bewertung zwischen eins und zehn bewerten? Du kannst nicht mehr einschlafen, ohne das Frühstücksfernsehen gesehen zu haben. Fünf. Zweitens, du stellst dir einen Wecker, ich möchte auch eine Reaktion von dir haben, so in einem Wort, du stellst dir einen Wecker, damit du noch vor Ladenschluss einkaufen kannst. Vier. Das wird immer einfach weniger oder was? Drittens. Wenn jemand sagt, wir treffen uns um zwölf, fragst du zwölf Uhr morgens? Drei. Viertens. Vogelgezwitscher macht dich schläfrig. Na, das finde ich nicht schlecht. Zwei. Es ist noch zu dunkel, um ins Bett zu gehen. Pi. Deine Nachbarn reagieren mittlerweile nicht mehr irritiert, dass du sie mit einem herzlichen Guten Morgen begrüsst, wenn sie von der Arbeit nach Hause kommen. Der ist gut, gefällt mir gut. Insgesamt würde ich dir wahrscheinlich eine Null geben, ja. Ja, es ist schon ein bisschen, aber man merkt, dass du ein bisschen mehr mittlerweile kannst. Ich meine, das war 2011, das war vor vier Jahren, also das ist schon wirklich ganze Weile. Das ist schlimm, das sehe ich gerade, 2011. Dafür ist es doch sehr gut. Ja, danke schön. Dafür ist es schon so eine Sitz. Ich habe jetzt sogar auch einen Kommentar bekommen auf dieser dubiosen Blogseite. Ehrlich? Wo man, wenn man auf Kommentare klickt, auf irgendwelche Spam-Mails kommt. Und warum machst du in jedem, also jeder, jeder, du konntest es auch taggen, also du konntest auch quasi jeden Beitrag mit Tags versehen und in jedem steht Gizmo. Why, why? Fand ich einen coolen Tag einfach, Gizmo fand ich ziemlich cool. Vor allem wenn jemand mal Gizmo googelt, finde ich es auch geil, wenn er halt nur darauf kommt, nur auf deine Seite kommt. Nur meine Blog-Entreide. Genau, alles von dir, das ganze Frontin-Will-Werk, Lebenswerk kannst du mit Gizmo ergoogeln. So, ich habe eine Anekdote und mehr nicht. Die Frage ist, wollen wir die jetzt raushauen oder nicht? Da können Sie in Stücken raushauen vielleicht. Das ist eine sehr knackige, sehr streng kontrollierte Anekdote. Dann hauen Sie jetzt raus. Und den Rest der Zeit, um mal ein bisschen Struktur reinzubringen, ein bisschen vorzuschauen, können wir uns mal diese Liste angucken, die ich gefunden habe, über Aufschieben, woran es bei uns liegt und dass wir es in Zukunft proaktiv bekämpfen können. Also ich war beim Kieferorthopäden und habe so einen Abdruck von meinem Gebiss gemacht. Und jeder, der es schon mal gemacht hat, weiss, dass es sehr unangenehm ist, weil man da halb würgereflexartig da in diesem Stuhl liegt. Und du konntest die Geschmacksrichtung aussuchen. Und ich kann mir die Geschmacksrichtung aussuchen und die Person, die das kontrolliert, halt auch nicht mit dir reden kann und dann halt einfach neben dir steht und einfach zwei Minuten abwartet und man nicht weiß, wo man hingucken soll. Und ich war in einer relativ modernen Kieferorthopädenpraxis, wo überall Fernseher hängen, also grosse Fernseher, auch in den normalen Behandlungsräumen und so, dass man eigentlich ständig Fernsehen schauen kann. Und da laufen ständig irgendwelche Natursachen, also irgendwelche Naturdokumentationen, wie Wald oder irgendwelche Fische, die schwimmen. Und bei mir war es eben, in diesem Raum war eben eine Kamera unter Wasser, die irgendwo da halt auf so einem Riff oder so aufgestellt wurde, eine starre Kamera und da schwammen dann lauter Fische rum davor und so Fischschwärme und so war sehr beruhigend alles. Aber dann schaue ich da hin und lasse mich da so ein bisschen hypnotisieren und verzaubern und ich bin da echt ganz entspannt und dieses Zeug im Mund und alles läuft gut, aber plötzlich ist so ein Fisch ganz nah an der Kamera vorbeigeschwommen und ich habe mich so erschrocken, so wirklich erschrocken und die Assistentin nimmt mich so, also in Ordnung, ist irgendwas passiert und ich so und ich konnte ihr natürlich auch nicht erklären, was gerade passiert war und es war jetzt auch nicht irgendwie ein Hai oder sowas oder das ist ja geil gewesen dann wird so ein riesen Hai so ein Seeungeheuer auftaucht irgendwie so das Ungeheuer von Loch Ness plötzlich in diesen Beruhigungsvideos auftaucht und es war so ein ganz gechillter kleiner Fisch der hat einfach nur wahnsinnig nah an der Kamera vorbeigeschwommen ist und das war echt so ein Moment wo ich mir dachte Alter dachte, Alter, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Überall lauert die Gefahr. Wo kann man denn noch hin? Selbst die Entspannungsvideos entsprechen dich. Aber es liegt vielleicht an dir, wenn selbst die Zahnarztvideos, die Entspannungsvideos beim Zahnarzt, die zu aufregend sind, dann hast du vielleicht die Kontrolle über dein Leben verloren. Aber solche Entspannungsvideos sind bei mir auf der Vertrauensskala wirklich ganz weit oben. Wirklich, wenn ich mich auf eines
verlassen können muss,
ja, wenn ich mich darauf verlassen können muss,
dann sind es solche Entspannungsvideos, dass da nichts
Schlimmes passiert. Es ist ein Ort der Harmonie und
Entspannung. Da darf nichts passieren. Und selbst
da lauert die Gefahr. Die Natur ist gnadenlos.
Die Natur ist wirklich gnadenlos, die hat keinen Sinn
für Entspannung. Hallo wie Entspannung?
Gibt's nicht. Vielleicht ist es aber auch wirklich so, dass sich da jemand einen Scherz erlaubt hat
und halt immer so
fünf Sekunden in jedem
zwei Stunden Loop-Video
Vielen Dank. sind wir Entspannung, Hallowie Entspannung, gibt's nicht. Vielleicht ist es aber auch wirklich so, dass sich da jemand einen Scherz erlaubt hat und halt immer so fünf Sekunden in jedem zwei Stunden Loop-Video sind so Erschreckmomente, vielleicht auch wenn irgendwie auf so einer Savanne und so und du die ganze Zeit beobachtest, dass du so ruhige Antilopen, dass einer plötzlich so ein Löwe kommt und einen zerfleischt einfach. Kann ja auch sein, dass hier jemand ein Scherz erlaubt. Ja, finde ich gut. Ja, ich habe immer mehr Vertrauen, ist weg. Also Vertrauen, ich verlieh immer mehr Vertrauen. Je älter man wird, desto weniger Vertrauen hat man. Und das passt jetzt zum Thema Aufschieben oder Zukunft? Nee, Zukunft, weil ich habe einfach mein Vertrauen in die Zukunft verloren, weil man nie weiss, was kommt. Sehr gut. Und das ist ja so ein bisschen das Spannende an der Zukunft, man weiss nicht, was passiert. Das ist eigentlich schon mein Fazit für die Folge, deswegen habe ich jetzt schon rausgehauen. Mal gucken, was sonst noch kommt. Findest du mal, wenn wir eine halbe Stunde Sendung machen, das findest du schlimm? Du meinst für die Zukunft? Nee, überhaupt nicht. Nee, für heute. Ah, du musst irgendwie weg oder was, ne? Nee. Du bist in Zeitdruck. Nee, aber du hast jetzt also ich sehe es nur pragmatisch. Du hast eine Anekdote vorbereitet, die ich habe immer keine. Du hast jetzt rausgehauen und wir sind genau jetzt an dem Punkt, wo wir schwimmen. Und deswegen habe ich überlegt, wie schlimm das wäre und dachte mir, ich mache es transparent, meine Gedanken. Nee, also ich weiß nicht. Natürlich würden jetzt die Zuschauer als Niederlage erkennen und das ist nicht so gut. Und natürlich, nein, ich glaube, wir müssen schon durchhalten. Das ist ja auch der Sinn der Sache. Okay, weißt du, was ich ... Stell dir mal vor, im Radio würde jemand sagen, sagen so, ey, wollen wir heute die ganze Stunde die Sendung machen oder hören wir jetzt auf?
Ja, lass uns aufhören,
aber spielen wir jetzt fünfmal im Loop Rhythm wie Wein von den Dritten Gäsen.
Aber das ist halt auch Aufschieben, das ist halt so dieses
Ach komm, dann machen wir jetzt nächste Woche ein bisschen länger.
Das ist Aufgeben, ja.
Das liegt relativ nah beieinander,
Aufschieben und Aufgeben. Eigentlich jedes Aufschieben
ist immer eine Kapitulation. Ist eine Art Synonym auch.
Ich hau meist
den zweiten Punkt raus, nee, den ersten haben wir noch gar nicht gehört, wir haben über fünf angefangen. Der erste Punkt auf der Liste, warum man aufschiebt, ist geringe Frustrationstoleranz. Wir besetzen eine sehr geringe Frustrationstoleranz, die zeigt sich zum Beispiel in Einstellungen wie Die Arbeit ist so anstrengend, steht hier wirklich. Also das stand hier nicht. Die Arbeit ist so anstrengend, unangenehm, lästig, langweilig. Was? Steht hier wirklich nicht, steht hier nicht. Was? Also hier steht wirklich jetzt in Anführungszeichen, die Arbeit ist so anstrengend, unangenehm, lästig, langweilig, deshalb vertage ich sie lieber. Oder ich habe keine Lust und ohne Lust kann ich die Arbeit nicht ertragen. Ich warte, bis ich Lust darauf habe. Passt das auf uns? Ich würde sagen ja. Hat das jemals jemand so formuliert, ich habe keine Lust und
ohne Lust kann ich die Arbeit nicht ertragen.
Ertragen vor allem. So als wäre es eine Folter.
Ja, also es passt
aber schon irgendwie auf, obwohl nein, eigentlich haben wir
uns aus Zeitgründen verschoben, oder?
Nee, natürlich auch aus Lust, wenn es zu lästig
und man keinen Bock drauf hat, verschiebt man es natürlich, ist ja klar.
Ja klar, also im Alltag, aber
auf den Podcast bezogen haben wir jemals verschoben,
weil wir gar keinen Bock drauf hatten. Nee, das glaube ich nicht, da waren es eher Zeitgründe. Aber du beziehst alles jetzt direkt auf den Podcast, oder was, du Ego-Schwein? Klassen Sie sich die Klinik und die Klinik und die Klinik und die Klinik und die K, Rebellion gegen Fortschriften. Wir sehen in der Aufgabe eine Verpflichtung, der wir nachkommen müssen. Die Aufgabe ist weder von uns ausgewählt noch erwünscht. Einstellungen hierzu sind, das ist unfair. Das können die nicht mit mir machen. Ich lasse mich doch nicht manipulieren. Denen werde ich es zeigen. Ich sollte das nicht tun müssen. Nee, glaube ich nicht. Das ist für mich ein Vorwand. Drittens, fehlendes Wissen... Rebellion, du kannst ja nicht alles mit Rebellion. Meine Rebellion ist einfach so ein Begriff Freiheit, den man einfach für jeden Scheiss bewenden kann. Es ist nicht alles eine Rebellion. Wenn du Dinge aufschiebst, ist es einfach keine Rebellion. Nein, das finde ich auch nicht. Vor allem Rebellion ist ja auch eigentlich, wenn man sich das schön redet oder irgendwie das ist Selbstmanipulation. Du redest dir selber ein, dass irgendwer dir das aufgezwungen hat. Das war echt einer der enttäuschendsten Momente meines Lebens. Ich habe nicht viel mit Assis zu tun, nur ab und zu wirklich. Und wirklich. Und ich bin, ich war tatsächlich, hatte man so eine Phase des militanten Nichtrauchertums und es war ja auf Bahnsteigen und so ist es ja so, dass man nur in gewissen Bereichen rauchen darf. Zumindest in München ist das so. Das ist auch überall so. Wirklich wie so Hühnerkäfige, so abgesteckte Bereiche, in denen man rauchen darf und ausserhalb nicht. Das finde ich auch sehr demütigend. Es ist wie im Zoo, die haben so einen Plexiglas-Bereich,hafen immer, man geht daran vorbei und Kinder stehen davor, zeigen darauf, oh guck mal Mama, Rauper. Ja, das sind Raucher, das sind andere Menschen als wir. Und dann war es so eine Situation, da hatte irgendwie so eine S-Bahn-Verspätung und dann wurde der Bahnsteig relativ voll und dann standen alle relativ eng aneinander und dann war eben so eine junge Familie, also Vater und Mutter mit einem Kind im Kinderwagen standen da und daneben eben so ein typischer Assi-Arsch, der geraucht hat. Und dann hat der Vater halt ihn so angeguckt und dann halt so und hat er so seinen Kinderwagen weggeschoben aus den Rauchschwaden raus und ich habe dem ganzen zugeschaut und habe ihn wirklich mit der grösstmöglichen Verachtung, also dem Raucher, mit der grösstmöglichen Verachtung angeschaut und dann hat er mich angeschaut und halt so ein, ja was guckst du denn? Und dann habe ich tatsächlich meinen ganzen Mut zusammengenommen und gesagt so, ja ich finde es nicht so gut, dass die hier rauchen, hier ist Raucher verboten. Und im Kopf geht es so, scheiße, was hast du da gesagt? Ja genau, alle Überlebensinstinkte an. Und dann hat er gesagt so, ja, ich finde es nicht so gut, dass sie hier rauchen, hier ist Rauchen verboten. Und im Kopf geht es so, scheiße, was hast du da gesagt, warum, warum? Und dann hat er gesagt so, ja, mir geht doch dich nichts an, da habe ich gesagt, ja, ich habe gerade beobachtet, dass der Herr hier gerade seinen Kinderwagen weggeschoben hat, weil sie direkt neben ihm geraucht haben und das finde ich nicht gut. Und dann hat sich seine Freundin eingeschaltet, die dann daneben stand und hat das Argument gebracht, wo ich bis heute den Hut ziehe, also ich fand es tatsächlich sehr gut, dass sie nicht direkt in Gewalt übergegangen sind, sondern erst noch argumentiert haben. Wir sind ja im Recht. Erst argumentiert und dann nicht verprügelt haben, damit du dich schlecht fühlst, zweifach. Genau, aber erst so dieses, ja wir sind ja im Recht und dann habe sie gesagt, ja, die S-Bahn kommt ja ständig zu spät, dann müssen wir uns auch nicht an die Regeln der Bahn halten. Und da war ich, da wurde ich komplett entwaffnet. Also wenn dir so diese Irrationalität mit so einem Schwall entgegenschwimmt, da stehst du erstmal ohne Waffen da, da bist du einfach nur nass und denkst, was ist das denn für ein Argument? Ja, oder du lachst, oder du fängst an zu lachen und kriegst direkt aufs Maul. Oder du rennst noch weg. Aber das ist wirklich die beste Waffe von dummen Menschen, ist Dummheit. Also man denkt, man könnte Leute, die dumm sind, schlagen, weil sie dumm sind. Nein, sie schlagen dich, weil sie dumm sind. Dummheit ist einfach die unschlagbare Waffe. Das stimmt. Weil Dummheit gleichzusetzen ist mit, man kann nicht verletzt werden. Man ist zu dumm, dass man überhaupt die Spielregeln nicht versteht und deswegen kann man auch nicht verlieren, weil man das Spiel einfach nicht versteht. Und da stand ich echt dann so da und dachte mir, das ist auch so eine Möchtige in Rebellion, dieses, ja, wenn die zu spät kommen, dann müssen wir uns nicht an deren Regeln halten. Und er sagte, die Regeln sind offensichtlich nicht zum Wohl der Bahn da aufgestellt worden,
sondern zum Wohl der Kunden und der Mitfahrer.
Das ist doch wirklich, was ist denn das für ein Schwachsinn?
Und selbst wenn es die Regeln nicht gäbe, ist es trotzdem assi,
da zu rauchen neben dem Kinderwagen und sich nicht darum zu scheren, wo man raucht.
Ich habe da noch eine ganze Weile diskutiert und es hat zu nichts geführt.
Hast du noch diskutiert?
Ich habe tatsächlich nur weitergeführt, da habe ich gesagt, ja, das ist doch egal. es geht doch darum, dass man nicht neben anderen Leuten raucht, das ist einfach scheiße. Und dann kamen noch irgendwie andere dumme Argumente, aber da war ich dann schon so geblendet und dass ich wirklich da echt nichts mehr mitbekommen habe. Null Einsicht gezeigt. Also ich habe gestern sowas erlebt. Ich war gestern in der Bahn, bin relativ spät nach Hause gefahren und dann sass neben mir ein ausländischer Mitbürger, der am Telefonieren war. Und dann war gegenüber irgendwie sacht ein Obdachloser, der auch schon sehr angesäuselt war und hat dann wohl auch seinen Schuh auf den Sitz des ausländischen Mitbürgers Türke. Wir sagen, wie es ist, es ist ein Türke. Er hat dann draufgelegt und der Türke war sauer. Und dann hat er, der Türke hat sein Telefonchen und hat den Schuh wieder wieder von seinem Sitz weggeschoben. Ich saß auch nur daneben, habe Musik gehört, bis ich dann gemerkt habe, dass die halt angefangen haben, irgendwie so leicht Aggressionen auszutauschen. Und dann wollten die sich prügeln. Und ich sass daneben und habe halt gelacht, weil ich es irgendwie lustig fand, dass sich plötzlich Leute prügeln, weil halt jemand einen Schuh auf den Sitz gelegt hat. Und dann musste der Obdachlose dann aber raus, der war auch völlig betrunken und dann hat er auch so angedeutet, ja komm mit, prügeln uns hier draußen und der ist dann aber ruhig geblieben. Und den Rest der Fahrt musste der Türke dann seiner Freundin erklären, warum er gerade offensichtlich Aggressionen ausgetauscht hat. Die Freundin am anderen Ende wollte das nicht begreifen, er hat wohl bestimmt gesagt, ja du reagierst immer wieder über über und so. Und er hat die ganze Zeit erklärt, nein, mir geht's gut und so. Und dann habe ich halt seinen Blick gesucht, weil ich es lustig fand, dass der Obdachlose so dermaßen ausgerastet ist plötzlich. Und dann unterbricht auf einmal er sein Telefonat und sagt mir, was ist mit dir, was ist dein Problem, was ist dein Problem. Auf einmal war ich plötzlich im Mittelpunkt, weil ich ihn angeguckt habe. Und ich so nein, alles gut, alles gut, alles gut. Und dann ist er irgendwann aufgestanden und stand die ganze Zeit so neben mir, so in so einer provokanten Haltung. Ich habe dann Musik gehört, irgendwie Barbie Girl, um mich abzureagieren, keine Ahnung. Und irgendwann... Das Aggressivste machen Sie Lied der Vail, hast du gehört. Ich weiß nicht. Und dann hat er aufgelegt und hat gesagt, ja, nee, sorry, war nicht so gemeint. Aber der Typ hat mich einfach aufgeregt. Und am anderen Ende der Leitung wurde ich auch die ganze Zeit missverstandenstanden und ja, weißt du, früher wäre ich ausgerastet, aber dann habe ich ein Anti-Aggression-Training gemacht und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, hat wohl offensichtlich nichts gebracht. Nein, das habe ich nicht gesagt. Natürlich, er hätte mich jetzt gewundert. Nein, da hat er mir das Anti-Aggression-Training nicht so ganz verstanden, wenn er sagt, so, ey, früher hätte ich dir noch eines auf die Fresse gegeben, aber jetzt habe ich ein Anti-Aggression-Thema, Nicht so ganz die richtige Einstellung irgendwie. Nee, vor allem er ist noch mega aggressiv, aber er setzt halt nicht mehr um und ihn frisst in sich rein, bis er irgendwann jemanden umbringt. Weiß ich nicht. Ja, finde ich besser, finde ich viel besser. Finde ich auch besser. Das ist gut. Gut, wunderbar. Danke, Stefan Titze, für diesen kleinen Ausflug in das Kölner Nachtleben. Grossartig, ja. Drittens, fehlendes Wissen und Streben nach Perfektion. Ich lese das immer vor. Vorwand, ist alles Vorwand. Der erste Grund war der einzige echte Grund, man hat keinen Bock, alle anderen sind nur Vorwände. Ist aber auch blöd, wenn man so eine Zehnerliste schreibt, ne, zehn Gründe fürs Aufschieben, klickt sich bestimmt gut. Ne, ist eine Neunerliste, ist eine Neunerliste. Man kann ja nicht nach zwei Gründen aufhören. Was ist die niedrigste Liste eigentlich? Also diese klassische Internet-Clickbait-Liste, so zwei Tipps, wie du sie ins Bett kriegst oder so. Zwei Tipps, wie du jede Frau ins Bett kriegst. Ein Tipp, ein Tipp, wie du in der Bar auf jeden Fall angesprochen bist. Was ist die niedrigste, die kleinste Liste? Der Titel verrät auch schon, wie gut es ist. Also wenn du halt nur einen Tipp hast, dann ist offensichtlich hoffentlich meist verloren. Das ist ein richtig guter Tipp. Oder es ist ein sehr guter Tipp ein sehr guter Tipp, ja. Ein Tipp für unattraktive Frauen, einen Mann zu bekommen. Aber da frage ich mich, warum der Autor dieser Aufschiebeliste nicht einen offensichtlichen Gag gemacht hat, wie Grund 1, ja, mir fällt gerade nichts, Grund 1 mache ich morgen, lies mal Grund 2 weiter. Grund 10 kommt morgen. Ja genau, Grund 10 kommt morgen, das sind neun, dass man da nicht mit dem Medium ein bisschen spiel kann. Mir ist zu wenig Humor in der Gesellschaft. Mich kotzt einfach an das Humor. Liegt das am Land? Liegt das am Land, denke ich mir oft. Es liegt am Land, aber es liegt natürlich auch an den Prioritäten, dass die Prioritäten nicht richtig gesetzt sind, dass man einfach nicht mal sagt, schau mal, stell dir mal vor. Oh, das ist Platz fünf. So Bundestagsansprachen wären lustig, so dass sich Leute unterhalten, so ey, hast du gestern die Bundestagsansprache gehört, war saulustig, was Merkel wieder rausgehauen hat.
Wenn die Leute einfach ein paar Gags, wenn es wirklich so in der Kultur ankommen würde, dass Lustig sein auch eine Tugend ist und dass man eben auch über ernsten Themen lustig sein kann, fände ich viel besser. Wenn es so eine Bundesagentur für Humor gäbe, die wirklich alles kontrolliert und Leute, die nicht lustig genug sind, abmahnt und sagst so, sie bauen da jetzt mindestens zwei Gags in ihren Gesetzes einen Entwurf ein oder und dann kommt noch ein Gag, weiss das ja die Bundesagentur für Humor, so was in der Richtung, dass die sowas machen, aber das ist... Ja, die jetzt nicht einfällt, weil auch du keine Ahnung. Ich glaube, es wird einem relativ, also wenn man das in Alltagssituationen, Humor entgegenspringt von dem, von diesen Situationen, wo man das nicht erwartet, dann glaube ich, nervt es relativ schnell. Also ich glaube, dann weißt du es nicht mehr zu schätzen, wenn jemand wirklich Humor benutzt, in der Freizeit zum Beispiel. Ne, ich finde, Humor sollte nicht so was Exklusives sein wie Humor. Das ist für mich auch ein Problem der Stand-Up-Comedy-Szene. Ich finde, deutsche Stand-Up-Comedy ist auch deswegen so schlecht, weil die Leute mit so einem Verständnis von, oh ja, jetzt wird's lustig. Natürlich sollen Stand-Up-Comedien lustig sein, natürlich sollte man auch mit einem Stand-Up-Comedie-Club gehen, mit der Erwartung, dass es lustig ist. Aber es sollte nicht so eine Exklusivität haben, so dieses Nur da ist lustig. Und ich glaube, dass das auch so ein Grund ist, dass deutsche Stand-Up-Comedians mit viel zu schlechten Gags durchkommen, weil die Leute schon in so einer, haha, das ist ja alles lustig und ich lache über jeden Satz, weil das hat auch schon diese Struktur, diese Melodie eines Gags und es wird sowieso über alles gelacht, anstatt dass man einfach sagt, hey, es gibt überall Gag, ich bin auch im Alltag lustig und so und dann ist es nur noch die Pro-Variante. In den USA gibt es ja auch oft diese Situation, dass, was ich in Deutschland noch gar nicht noch nie erlebt habe, dass Senn-Up-Comedians relativ häufig auch angegangen werden, wenn sie unlustig sind. Also dann wird relativ sehr ehrlich gesagt, du bist scheiße, geh bitte von der Bühne. Es gibt oft Leute, die dazwischenrufen bei Gags. Und es ist so, dass die Leute, wenn was witzig ist, alle sehr, sehr laut stark lachen, sehr, sehr laut und dann ganz abrupt aufhören. So nach dem Motto, so, das habe ich jetzt gehört, ich will bitte jetzt den nächsten Gag. Wenn so eine Crowd plötzlich ganz laut lacht und dann schlagartig aufhört, das ist, glaube ich, für ausländische Comedians relativ schwierig, das erstmal zu verstehen. Ich glaube auch, je lustiger der Durchschnittsbürger eines Landes ist, desto lustiger sind auch die Comedians dieses Landes. Es ist wahrscheinlich nicht sind ja die. Das ist wahrscheinlich nicht so die Mördererkenntnis, aber ich glaube, je lustiger man im Alltag ist, desto lustiger erwartet man auch, dass Stand-up-Comedians sind. Und ich glaube genau, dass eben Stand-up-Comedians in Deutschland mit zu schlechten Gags zu weit kommen, weil die Leute einfach im Alltag so unfassbar unlustig sind, dass selbst der Sprung von null lustig zu den acht Prozent lustig schon gross genug ist, um den Ausflug zu rechtfertigen. Und das ist Quatsch. Was glaubst du, ist das lustigste Land der Welt? England oder Amerika, aber ich könnte mir jetzt hätte ein Gag kommen sollen, jetzt hätte ein Gag kommen müssen, um sowas wie Narnia oder so. Absurdistan. Und wenn ihr gelacht habt, dann liegt es an Deutschland. Wenn ihr gelacht habt, dann liegt es an Deutschland. Es ist scheiße. Das war kein guter Gag. Seid stolz auf euch, wenn ihr jetzt nicht gelacht habt. Das war kein guter Gag. Und ihr habt nicht zu lachen bei diesem Gag. Weil er war nicht lustig. Er war acht Prozent lustig und man hat ab fünfzig Prozent zu lachen. Ich finde tatsächlich, dass man seinen Humor viel mehr dadurch definieren kann, worüber man nicht lacht, als worüber man lacht. Man sagt, Humor ist, wenn man trotzdem lacht. Das würde dagegen sprechen. Gut, dann haben wir jetzt zwei gegenüberstehende Meinungen. Ich finde auch, über Humor zu reden, wo wir gerade irgendwie da sind zu verfallen, es ist das Unlustigste der Welt. Es hat mal jemand gesagt, es ist wie ein Frosch zu sezieren, man weiss danach alles über den Frosch, aber er stirbt halt dabei. Auch das war jetzt wahnsinnig unlustig, aber relativ schlau von demjenigen, der es gesagt hat. Aber wollen wir mal Witze erklären, also wirklich Comedy erklären? Wollen wir mal wirklich da rangehen? Ja, komm, lass uns das mal machen, das ist dann wieder eine sehr unlustige Folge, aber naja, ihr wisst ja mittlerweile, worauf ihr euch einlasst. Also, halt du doch mal ein kurzes Impulsreferat über die L-Form. Die L-Form. Die L-Form, ich möchte, dass ihr euch jetzt die Augen schliesst, ein bisschen Fische anmacht am Fernsehen. Und dann wollen wir uns die L-Form vor Augen führen. Es ist ja ein gerader Strich, ein senkrechter gerader Strich und ein vertikaler Strich, der etwas kürzer ist. Wir beginnen am Ende des senkrechten langen Strichs. Man wird in eine Richtung geführt, wird sogar noch weiter in die Richtung geführt. Man hat eine gewisse Erwartung, dass es weiter in die Richtung geht, warum sollte man von was anderem ausgehen? Und dann plötzlich wird man abgelenkt. Komplett das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Plötzlich wird man abgelenkt und landet auf dem senkrechten Strich, auf dem vertikalen Strich. Und dann fragt man sich, wo ist man jetzt? Wo ist man jetzt? Was soll ich tun? Ich bin hier verloren und man aus Versehen lacht man. Ich würde sagen, wir überführen dieses Konzept einfach mal direkt in deinen letzten Gag, in deinen letzten Tweet. Ich würde dir das mal vorlesen und dann erklärst du mir bitte, wie dieses Konzept anzubieten. Okay, Pornhub erfindet Wankband. Stromanbieter müssen im Hause Edati in Zukunft sogar noch draufzahlen. Sehr schlecht rübergebracht, der Gag ist okay. Wo ist die L-Form?
Die L-Form ist, einen Moment, ich muss ihn selber mal kurz vor Augen haben, das ist natürlich jetzt gemein auch ein bisschen.
Also die L-Form ist das klassische Feedline-Punchline-Prinzip.
Also es gibt einen Teil des Gags, der selbst nicht lustig ist, aber die Punchline, also die Pointe vorbereitet, die Feedline, das wäre der senkrechte Strich,
und dann eben die Punchline, die die von diesem Weg maximal irritierend ablenkt. Also Pornhub erfindet ein Wankband. Ich habe das zu einer Fernsehsendung geschrieben, deshalb muss man ein bisschen mehr Wissen da eigentlich jetzt voraussetzen. Also das Wankband ist ein Ding, womit man beim Onanieren Strom erzeugen kann. Das heißt, man denkt in diese Richtung, oh, da gibt es vorher schon eine Erfindung. Stromanbieter müssen im Hause Edati in Zukunft sogar noch draufzahlen. Ja. Also wo ist jetzt, definier mal genau den Punkt, wo ist der 90-Grad-Knick? Wo ist der exakte Punkt des 90-Grad-Knicks? Der exakte Punkt ist, dass Stromanbieter, die ja offensichtlich immer viel Geld verlangen, im Hause Edati … Wo ist der Moment, wo ist der Punkt? Draufzahlen, es ist der Moment Draufzahlen. Bei welchem Wort? Hm, bitte? Das letzte Wort ist die Pointe, oder was? Das ist natürlich ein Musterbeispiel, weil die Pointe sollte immer ganz am Ende stehen. Okay. Der davor ist ein bisschen einfacher. Gut, anscheinend wollte die Stripperin keine 20 Euro zugesteckt bekommen. Ist klar, anscheinend hat sie das Geld abgelehnt oder war ein bisschen sauer. Sie wollte 20 Euro nicht haben. Warum? Wer nicht will, der hat schon? Jetzt kommt die Punchline. Aber ich hatte es halt nur sehr, sehr klein. Oh mein Gott, das ist super Gang. Wir wollen mehr so Gangs. Wow. Das ist halt jetzt eine typischere Punchline, weil es ein Bild auch noch im Zuhörer auslöst, nämlich man hat anscheinend der Stripperin Kleingeld zugesteckt.
Aha, also sind wir hier in einer absurden Situation.
Man ist in einer absurden Situation, eine augenscheinlich normale Situation, wird plötzlich, jemand lehnt Geld ab, wird plötzlich etwas bildhafter.
Jemand hat einer Stripperin ganz viel Kleingeld zugesteckt. Ist halt ein Bild, was ausgelöst wird im Kopf des Zuhörers.
Also muss ein Witz immer absurd sein? Nö. Gut, nächster Punkt auf deiner Liste. Hältst du dich denn immer an die L-Form? Nee, du bist doch einer, der so ein bisschen nur weirder schreibt. Du hast auch so ein bisschen nur weirderen Humor. Tatsächlich manchmal schon, aber ich finde tatsächlich, ich finde die Königsdisziplin ist, wenn die Pointe schon in der Feedline angelegt ist. Alle haben sich über Van Gogh lustig gemacht, als er sein Ohr abgeschnitten hat. Aber wisst ihr, was er gesagt hat? Ich verstehe euch nicht. Genau. Und das meine ich, dass die Pointe ja schon vorausgegriffen wurde in der Feedline wegen dem Ohr. Dass es nicht ganz absurd ist, sondern dass man es vielleicht eigentlich schon hätte wissen können, aber noch nicht gewusst hat. Also man führt den Zuschauer bewusst in die Irre, ohne dass er es merkt. Und der Zuschauer muss sich dann aber eingestehen, ja, eigentlich hat es schon Hand und Fuß, es ist nicht komplett aus der Luft gegriffen. Anwalt, Herr Will, wo waren Sie am Abend des Ich-Zuhause? Den fand ich ja persönlich sehr lustig. Ein Kompliment kurz? Dankeschön, vielen Dank, ja. Ja, also an der Stelle, wenn ihr uns noch nicht auf Twitter folgt, wir sind zwei richtig gute Gagkanonen, die richtig ordentlich was abfeuern. An guten Tagen, an guten Tagen, da bin ich ehrlich, ich habe meistens nichts raus. Und an guten Tagen kommt mal was, aber es ist auch nicht unbedingt gut. Pommes Ruppel, du heisst Pommes unterstrich Ruppel. Das ist richtig, und du heisst Stefan Titzel. Jan Böhm, at Jan Böhm. Gut, ja, das war jetzt zum Beispiel ein Gag, weil man hätte jetzt erwartet, dass man den Namen von Stefan Titzel sagt, und er hat aber den Namen von Uli Schulz gesagt, und deswegen war das ein Gag. So, nächster Punkt auf der Liste. Auf der Aufschiebenliste? Ja, die wollen wir nicht aufschieben. Falsches Zeitmanagement. Wir unterschätzen den Zeitaufwand, der für die Arbeit notwendig ist, beziehungsweise die Zeit, die wir zur Verfügung haben. Nein, falsch, völlig falsch. Finde ich auch falsch, aber … Wir überschätzen den Zeitaufwand. Genau. Wir sagen immer im Sinne von, ja, wollen wir jetzt noch anfangen zu drehen? Hat doch keinen Sinn mehr. 16 Uhr, nee, dann ist es schon dunkel, wenn wir da sind. Und dann müssen wir eh erst mal den Kran aufbauen. Wir drehen doch ohne Kran. Ja, aber wenn wir dann das Objektiv vergessen haben, bis wir nochmal zurück. Aber wir drehen doch unobjektiv. Ja, aber wir haben das jetzt noch gar nicht geprobt. Aber wir drehen doch gar nichts. Ja, aber ich meine, wenn wir dann jetzt wirklich jetzt erst losgehen, weil wir im Zeitplan … Aber wir sind doch schon da. Ja, aber wenn wir jetzt erst alles aufgebaut haben … Aber wir brauchen gar nichts aufbauen. Ja, aber ich meine, morgen ist wahrscheinlich besseres Wetter und dann können wir es vielleicht nochmal irgendwie besser drehen. Und ich bin jetzt mit dem Skript auch noch nicht so hundertprozentig, ob wir da nicht nochmal reinschauen können.
Ja, das ist nämlich das Problem. Das ist nämlich genau das Problem, glaube ich. Also man sucht sehr viele Ausreden immer, aber im Endeffekt kommt immer alles darauf zurück, dass man keinen Bock hat. Ja, natürlich. Und manchmal sind diese Ausreden sogar, also kann man tatsächlich da mit Idealismus viel machen. So im Sinne von, naja, also was man glaube ich sehr oft hört ist, naja, bevor wir es jetzt unter Zeitdruck machen, machen wir es doch lieber morgen gescheit. In Ruhe, wir machen es morgen in Ruhe. Morgen ist ein ganzer Tag noch. Und da zwingt man alle Zuhörer dazu, einzustimmen, weil niemand möchte sagen, nein, wir rotzen jetzt einfach irgendwas hin. Wenn man die Situation so etabliert, wenn man die moralischen Prinzipien so verteilt, heute schnelles, schludriges, schlechtes Produkt, morgen gutes Produkt, kann eigentlich der Zuhörer gar nicht anders als für morgen appellieren, wenn man die Situation so aufgebaut hat. Es hilft auch, sogar habe ich mal gehört, dass wenn man nickt bei etwas, was man sagt, wenn man selber nickt bei dem, was man selber sagt, dass der Zuhörer, egal wer es findet, erst mal so instinktiv mitnickt. Und dieses Nicken sind wir ja so konditioniert, dass wir es gut finden, was man sagt. Und das ist ganz interessant eigentlich. Deswegen kommen Wackeldackel auch so gut an. Soll ich das kaufen? Ja, du sollst mich kaufen. Das ist eigentlich ganz gut, ob nickende Produkte tatsächlich häufiger gekauft werden als Kopfschüttel. Deswegen fährt man Autos mit Wackeldackel hinten drin auch immer gerne hinterher, weil man denkt, das ist schon richtig. Das ist schon richtig gut hierher fahren. Folgen Sie diesem Auto. Wie oft ist mir schon vorkommen, dass ich auch immer irgendwo in der Pampa gelandet bin, weil ich im Wagen mit Wackeldackel hinterher gefahren bin? Ich dachte, du machst es andersrum. Ich dachte, du sagst, wie oft es mir schon passiert ist, dass jemand mich verfolgt hat, nur weil ich einen Wackeldacken hatte. Aber gut, man kann nicht immer mal das haben. Es ist beides kein guter Gag, aber es ist okay. Aber bei uns ist Zeitwinkel, glaube ich, ein grosses Ding. Also wir nehmen ja nicht auf, weil wir keinen Bock haben, sondern weil wir einfach keine Zeit manchmal haben. Du bist am Drehen. Ich habe auch was zu tun manchmal. Ich habe auch nicht jeden Abend Zeit. Ich bin auch mal mit Freunden im Kino oder habe mit Frauen verabredet. Wann warst du das letzte Mal mit Freunden im Kino? Oder bin manchmal auch weg abends oft viel und habe auch Spaß und gehe tanzen in der Disco, yeah, bin ich auch oft. Ja, deswegen haben wir ja auch teilweise auch keine Zeit dafür. Tust du manchmal so, als hättest du für was keine Zeit, nur um dich interessanter zu machen? Relativ häufig sogar. Aber meistens ist auch das darauf zurückzufinden, dass ich keinen Bock auf diese Sache habe. Deswegen sage ich, ich habe was anderes zu tun, weil wenn ich sage, ich habe keinen Bock, dann kommt immer dieses, oh, oh, Idiot, Pussy. Aber eigentlich ist dieses, hast du heute Abend schon was vor, eigentlich fast schon eine Beleidigung. Aber eigentlich muss man sagen, ja klar, ich habe jeden Abend was vor, ich bin ein total krasse Typ, so. Eigentlich kann man Verabredungen am selben Abend eigentlich nur abschlagen. Man ist glaube ich insgesamt, sind viele, die meisten Leute, liebe Leute, sind Verlierer. Und deswegen kann man davon ausgehen. Es gibt mehr Verlierer als Gewinner, oder? Ja, durchschnittlich ja. Und deswegen würde ich sagen, dass die meisten Leute haben jeden Abend nicht viel zu tun. Und ich glaube, dass die meisten machen sich ja selber nur interessant. Viele Sachen, die einem selber peinlich sind, die man selber versucht zu suggerieren bei anderen, die sind ja bei anderen auch nicht besser. Verstehst du? Ich glaube, viele Leute sagen, machen das, was wir so machen. Und deswegen, ich glaube, es ist im Endeffekt nicht schlimm. Irgendwann sind wir nicht uncool, sondern die ganze Welt ist halt relativ uncool. Wow, ich glaube, das war, du hast da gerade echt was gesagt, das war echt ein schönes Zitat. Ich habe echt was gesagt. Ist da ein Tweet drin? Cap Nobius, wow, du hast echt was gesagt. Du hast gerade Hammer was gesagt. Ja, nee, ist kein Tweet drin. Nein. Aber wenn man da ein bisschen schürft, komm da. Ich würde mit dir jetzt gerne ein Tweet basteln. Ich würde gerne. Ob uns nicht was zusammen... Also ganz kurz, ich sage dir mal ganz kurz. Ich habe immer so ein Dokument, wo ich so Tweet-Ideen habe, wo ich mir was überlege und wo ich Tweets generiere. Und ich habe jetzt hier zum Beispiel einen, der ist bei mir relativ hoch gerutscht. Ich habe da immer so eine Skala, wie hoch die Tweets kommen. Und ab einem gewissen Wert poste ich sie oder poste sie dir, damit du sie absiegeln kannst. Und ich gebe dir eine Zahl, bis zehn gebe ich dir eine Zahl. Ja, da gibst du da nochmal eine Zahl. Und zum Beispiel habe ich einen Tweet, und da bin ich mir nicht sicher, weil Tweets sind oft nicht so lustig, aber Twitter ist jetzt auch nicht eine Plattform, wo man nur Witze postet, sondern auch mal so ein, ah, süss oder kenn ich oder was für ein netter Gedanke, halt so ein Nettigkeit, ich nenne es jetzt mal Cuteness-Moment. Und da habe ich zum Beispiel in die Kategorie fällt vielleicht noch oder so vielleicht so ein, es ist eher awesome als wirklich lustig. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Ja, bin ich gut. Und hau jetzt wieder raus. Schlechtes fucking Setup ever. Und zwar habe ich jetzt geschrieben, Pinguine haben von allen Tieren den besten Modegeschmack. So, und das ist sowas von mega unkreativ und scheisse, dass ich ja gar nicht, ich konnte mich gar nicht erbarmen, dafür eine Zahl zu geben. Aber nein, aber schau mal, es gibt ja dieses Klischee von wegen Pinguine tragen Wack. Ja, natürlich gibt es das Klischee. Und alle Menschen sagen das. Und da jetzt zu sagen, die haben den besten Modegeschmack, ist das nicht so. Ja, aber das ist doch total cute, so verstehst du, da kann der Zuschauer dann auch drauf kommen, so mit dem Wack und so. Ja, natürlich kann er drauf kommen. Er hat den Gedanken selber schon zehn Mal in seinem Leben, wie jeder Mensch. Ja, aber allein die Idee, dass Tiere, die per se keine Kleidung tragen, dass es eine Tierart gibt, die den besten Modegeschmack hat, obwohl niemand Kleidung trägt. Ich finde, das ist okay. Das ist vom Gedanken her, ist das in Ordnung. Poste ihn mal jetzt bitte, wir haben ja noch Zeit am Ende, wir können ja jetzt noch eine Viertelstunde lang, können wir gucken und selber live überprüfen, wie gut der Tweet funktioniert.
Und go!
Hau ihn raus!
Also die Frage ist, was ist,
also meine Regel ist immer fünf Minuten fünf Faves.
Okay.
Ich hau ihn mal raus. Okay, hau ihn raus. Oder soll ich ihn mit dem Podcast UV-Found raushauen? Nein, nein, nein, du musst
ihn mit Florentin Will raushauen.
Du hast es getan, ich sehe es. Aber guck,
ich glaube, dass die Resonanz relativ hoch wird,
weil viele eben so, ah, cute,
ha, Tiere sind einfach gut, irgendwie
Die mit Florentin will raushauen. Du hast es getan, ich sehe es. Aber guck, ich glaube, dass die Resonanz relativ hoch wird, weil viele eben so, ah, cute, haha,
Tiere sind einfach gut, irgendwie
so Tiere, vermenschlichte
Tiere kommen immer total gut an.
Also auch so dieses ganze Katzennösel,
so Katzen
sind ja wie Menschen
bis... Ich finde es total geil, wenn man aus den Gedanken
von Tieren spricht. Also wenn Tiere
sich artikulieren könnten, glaube ich, hätten die teilweise echt sehr lustige Gedanken.
Okay, da habe ich auch einen auf Lager.
Okay, bin geschwankt.
Achtung, aber ich sage jetzt Sternchen als Regieanweisung. Sternchen, Regieanweisung, Sternchen.
Okay.
Also, gesprochene Rede, wir sollten definitiv mehr Eukalyptus im Büro haben. Sternchen, Koala-Bär-Chef nickt Sternchen. Finde ich gut. Aber das ist halt ... Ich finde diese Tierwitze total geil. Vor allem, ich würde sagen, ich würde noch vielleicht etwas mehr Bild reinbringen, Koala-Bär-Chef steht auf und klatscht langsam, fände ich auch irgendwie eine ganz geile Nummer.
Also einfach so ein Bild erzeugen beim anderen.
Das sind auch diese Formen, in die man ganz gut reinschreiben kann.
Ich zum Beispiel, ich hatte mal, wir haben uns auch immer zusammen diese Form überlegt,
Menschen, die zum ersten Mal etwas machen.
Also wer war der erste Mensch, der Popcorn erfunden hat?
Ja, genau.
Was muss er gedacht haben? Was zur Hölle geht ihr vor?
Oder die Person, die die Umarmung erfunden hat.
Der erste Mensch, der jemals geklatscht hat, nach einer künstlerischen Leistung. Wie entsteht so was? Das sind halt auch so Formen, in die man ganz gut reinschreiben kann, glaube ich. Aber ganz kurz, jetzt nochmal zurück zu dem Koala-Bär-Gag. Widerspricht es nicht ein bisschen deiner Prämisse, dass Pointen möglichst kurz sein sollen? Also ich habe jetzt Koala-Bär-Chef nickt. Im Vergleich zu Koala-Bär-Chef steht auf und klatscht. Das sind doppelt so viele Worte. Ja, also die Pointe muss am Ende stehen. Er ist halt auch deutsch, deshalb haben wir schon mal das Thema. Deutsch ist echt fucking scheisse. Naja, im Englischen wäre es das auch nicht so. Clap slowly.
Ja, klatsch langsam ist exakt dasselbe.
Das ist oft so. Das ist auch die grösste Pfeife der Welt.
Du durchdenkst wirklich
nichts. Also ich habe bei dir schon so
oft dich dabei erwischt, wie du einfach
Bullshit sagst, dann das Thema wechseln willst.
Aber wenn man mal sich ganz genau zuhört,
was Stefan Titzel den ganzen Tag so raushaut, merkt man, dass wirklich 90 Prozent oder mehr völlig haltet. Das ist doch alles eine Riesen... Ich habe mir diese Rolle am Schreibtisch ausgedacht. Ich habe mir diese Rolle am Schreibtisch... Es ist Platz neun auf deiner tollen Liste, ist ja alles nur eine Rolle. Also wir sind bei zwei Minuten, ein Faith, ein Retweet. Das ist eine katastrophale Quote für mich. Ein Faith, ein Retweet. Ja, nach zwei Minuten es funktioniert. Und der Retweet hat 96 Follower. Okay, soll ich den Koala-Bern mal raushauen? Hau den Koala-Bern jetzt raus. Okay, ähm. Aber, wie gesagt. Steht auf und klatscht, habe ich jetzt, oder klatscht langsam? Langsam, langsam ist, das ist, glaube ich, wichtig. Steht auf, klatscht langsam. Steht auf und klatscht langsam. Koala-Beer-Chef steht auf und klatscht langsam. Auch als Regieranweisung. Ja, also in eckigen Klammern, wie du es gerne möchtest. Genau, steht auf, klatscht langsam. So, jetzt gibt es erstmal direkt von mir ein Sternchen. Ja, man muss ja auch mitspielen, aber ich glaube, der funktioniert ganz gut. Ah ja, danke. Stefan Titzel favorisierte, vielen Dank. Vielleicht sollte ich ein E noch in meinen Namen einbauen. Mond ist in den Ozean gefallen, habe ich mir auch als Gag aufgeschrieben, aber ich weiß nicht genau, wo das hinführen sollte. Ich finde auch Replayer, also Leute, die bei Twitter antworten, haben alle einen Schaden. Ja, wirklich, durch die Bank. 100 pro Antworten hat jemand ... Durch die Bank. 100 pro antwortet jemand, wie, wie konnte das denn passieren? Oder ehrlich, hat die NASA auf Twitter noch nicht geschrieben. Sowas. Es kommt da was zurück, wo man halt null Ahnung hat, was man darauf antworten soll wiederum. Oder man weiss auch nicht, ob es ein Scherz ist oder ob die einfach dämlich sind.
Oh Jesus, okay, okay, ein ehemaliger Neo-Magazin-Autor hat favorisiert.
Okay, nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht.
Ehemalig.
Aber am allerbesten fand ich es, er habe mich einen Tweet rausgehauen und dann hat jemand geantwortet mit
Klassischer Janue, J-A-N-U-E. Was? Und what? Also ist das ein Insider von euch oder was? Oder wollt ihr nicht verstanden werden oder was ist da los? Ich habe mal geschrieben, gibt es eigentlich rechtefreie Bilder von Pegida-Aktivisten? Rechtefreie, Zwinker, Zwinker, rechtefreie Bilder von Pegida. Und einer hat irgendwie geantwortet, nein, aber kann sein, dass du Probleme mit öffentlich-rechtlichen Sendern bekommst, dann. Aber ich glaube an das Gute im Menschen, ich glaube, dass es auch ein Gag war, wegen öffentlich-rechtlich. Selbst dann hat es keinen Sinn ergeben, selbst dann, wenn er es so gemeint hätte, dass man das formuliert, das glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube schon. Oder ich habe getwittert, ich unterschreibe nichts mehr, bevor ich nicht so getan hätte, als hätte ich es gelesen. Antwort, weniger ist mehr. Spaß beiseite. Aber weniger ist mehr ist auch so ein Satz, mit dem kann man auf alles antworten. Wenn einem nichts einfällt, wenn man einfach antworten möchte, weniger ist mehr. Okay. Alles klar. Also der Koala-Bär. Das sind diese Catch-Faces, die man raushauen muss zwischendurch. Weniger ist mehr. Einfach, du hast immer einen Satz, den du sagen kannst. Der passt irgendwie immer. Oder irgendwie auch immer nicht so richtig. Er hat sechs Faves, der Koala-Bär. Ja, in zwei Minuten sechs. Das sieht schon nicht schlecht aus. Aber siehst du, die Leute mögen halt einfach Tiere, eben anthropomorphisierte Tiere. Darauf stehen die Leute einfach. Ja, genau wie dein Pinguin-Tweet eben famos gezeigt hat. Ja, der war vielleicht ein bisschen doof. Ja. Ganz kurz, fällt dir eine lustige Situation ein, zu diesen Flughäfenempfängen. Wurdest du schon mal an einem Flughafen von deiner Familie mit grossen Transparenten und Kostümen und gleichen T-Shirts empfangen? Nie. Und ich gehe wirklich zu, also da könnte ich jetzt wirklich sehr, sehr viel Geld drauf wetten, dass ich nie so empfangen werde. Nie, niemals. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, wie das passieren soll, dass irgendwann mal meine ganze Familie und meine Freunde da stehen und Welcome home und wir haben alles gleiche T-Shirt an. Irgend so ein Typ, ein Onkel, den ich davor angerufen habe, irgendwie, ja, ich hole dich ab, deine Mutter hat gesagt, ich soll dich abholen. Aber mehr nicht, niemals. Es ist aber mal ein bisschen unangenehm, weil wie reagiert man darauf? Also irgendwann haben sie alle zu Ende gefreut und dann steht man halt da am Flughafen, alle haben das gleiche T-Shirt an, vielleicht hast du selber das T-Shirt mittlerweile auch an, weil die das auch irgendwie gedruckt haben und dann steht man da, hat sie nichts mehr zu erzählen, war gut, man ist auch fertig vom Flug und auf einmal stehen da alle und alle haben halt diese, wieder so ein Gesicht von, ja gut, war vielleicht doch nicht so eine gute Idee und man steht da halt überall rum. Aber gibt es etwas menschenverachtenderes als passende T-Shirts, also zu egal welchem Anlass, klassisches Beispiel Junggesellenabschied oder oder solche Empfänge. Wenn eine Gruppe Menschen gleiche T-Shirts anhat, können die von mir aus sofort weg eigentlich, weil da kann nichts Gutes rauskommen. Das ist wirklich dumme Menschen in Massen und Menschen mit gleichen T-Shirts, da kann nichts Gutes bei rauskommen, egal was. Hattet ihr Abi-T-Shirts? Ja, wir hatten Abi-T-Shirts, aber ich habe es nicht gekauft tatsächlich. Wir mussten das kaufen und die waren sehr schlecht, also die waren sehr schlecht. Das Bild war verpixelt darauf, weil die Leute irgendwie mit falschen Farbprofilen gearbeitet haben. Hätte ich auch nicht besser gekonnt, aber die haben die Aufgabe an sich genommen. Und dann dachte ich mir auch, wenn die Leute die Aufgabe wollen, dann haben die auch Ahnung davon. Das war verpixelt, es war uncharf, es war mit Hand gezeichnet, keine Ahnung. Und dann war es mit so ganz schlechter draufgedrückt.
Und bei der Abiturfeier sollten wir es alle anhaben,
da hat es keiner mehr getragen, weil kein Bock mehr da war.
Was war denn dein Abi-Motto?
Das ist jetzt wirklich das unkreativste Motto der Welt.
Es war Abi Potter, wir verlassen die Kammer des Schreckens.
Es ist noch nicht mal ein gutes Wortspiel.
Es ist nichts.
Abi!
Es ist nichts. Es ist nichts. Abi Potter! Es ist so gut, wenn es nicht mal der Versuch eines Wortspiels ist. Es ist Brainstorming viel zu spät abgebrochen. Das war so ein ... Na gut, komm, dann zeigen wir wenigstens, dass wir nicht mal versuchen, ein Wortspiel zu versuchen. Wir haben nicht mal der Versuch, wird gewagt, ein gutes Wortspiel hinzubekommen. Wie gut ist das? Ich war damals für How I Get My Abi, da war damals How I Met Your Mother sehr. Ist auch nicht so gut, aber es war halt zur Auswahl. Was wart ihr? Wir waren der Jahrgang mit den meisten Attestpflichten, die verteilt wurden. Also das, wenn man fehlt vom Unterricht, dass man dann Attest nachliefern muss, um zu zeigen, dass es gründen muss, und manche Schüler, die oft fehlen, haben dann diese Attestpflicht bekommen, und deswegen haben wir unseren Abi-Jahrgang Abi-Testpflicht genannt. Also Topical, irgendwie was Besonderes, fand ich es auch nicht überragend, aber... Wir waren der erste Doppeljahrgang, also wir waren ja, wir waren die Ersten, die nach zwölf Jahren Abi gemacht haben, vor uns sind ja 13 Jahre, wir sind zu zweit, also zwei Jahrgänge auf einmal haben Abi gemacht. Da kannst du nicht irgendwie A, B. Ja, wir wollten uns erst nennen, Abigasmus, wir kommen doppelt. Oder A, B, neugierig. So was, aber wurde uns verboten, sexuelle Sachen wurden uns verboten. Echt, ich habe mal von einem Jahrgang gehört, der hieß Penis, Penis, Penis, Bums, Bums. Nee, dieses Abitur, 13 Jahre Konzentration und jetzt geben wir Gas. So als Nazi. Ja, aber das, also. Aber ich glaube, mit Abi war auch noch irgendwas, Abi Hitler oder so was. Keine Ahnung, irgendwas in der Richtung. Ich bin ziemlich stolz auf Abi, neugierig, ich glaube, den haue ich raus. Völlig ohne Kontext, einfach haue ich raus. Vielleicht mit meinem Fake-Account. Ach schon mal, acht Favoriten in sechs Minuten, es ist nicht so gut eigentlich. Es entwickelt sich nicht so gut eigentlich. Aber ich weiss es nicht. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, Leute, jetzt geht es aber los. Jetzt geht es los, jetzt kommen die grossen Leute,
die dich retweeten. Oh, oh, oh, da hat jemand
retweetet, ja, aber den kenne ich gar nicht. Es ist übrigens so, dass
Leute, die retweeten und null Follower
haben, die grössten Arschlöcher auf diesem
Planeten sind. Die wollen einen demütigen
und ich hasse sie. Und du hasst sie und alle
Menschen hassen sie. Ich finde, man sollte erst ab einer
gewissen Followerzeit retweeten dürfen, weil ansonsten
freut derjenige, der retweetet oder
sich drüber, ohne dass tatsächlich was dabei rumkommt. Das finde ich einfach furchtbar. Das war eine Twitter-Nerd-Folge. Ja, das war die Folge 10. Eine Twitter-Nerd-Folge, die komplett unlussig war. Ne, wie du moderierst ab. Was? Hä? Ich bin gerade zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben, es war wie so ein Flash, mir ist schwarz vor Augen geworden, ich habe plötzlich angefangen zu moderieren. Das war, boah, es war wie so ein, oh, und du reisst mich da einfach so raus. Man darf Schlafwandel im Männchen auch nicht aufwecken. Achtung, einen habe ich noch. Letztens ich so zu meinem besten Freund, manchmal fühle ich mich irgendwie leer und ohne Antrieb und dann eher nur so zum Mitnehmen oder zum Hieressen. Den fand ich sehr gut. Auch, ne, man baut eine Erwartungshaltung auf. Wie trocken ich schon bin. Ich lache noch nicht mehr darüber. Ich sage einfach, ja, der ist sehr gut. Der ist sehr gut, der kriegt neun Punkte. Aber das habe ich tatsächlich schon häufiger gehört in amerikanischen Podcasts und sowas, dass Comedians nicht über Gags lachen, weil sie sofort im Analyse-Modus drin sind und sofort sagen, ja, sehr gut gemacht. Genauso wie sich Horrorfilm-Regisseure nicht in Horrorfilmen erschrecken, sondern sagen, sehr gut. Da wie dieser Dämon aus dem Schrank gesprungen ist, sehr gut. Wie plötzlich der Fisch vor der Kamera erschien. Sehr unerwartet. Eigentlich ist Horror und Comedy relativ ähnlich. Ja, finde ich auch. Man baut immer eine Situation auf und versucht dann zu schocken. Es ist auch bei mir so, ich finde die lustigsten Filme, also die Filme, die ich am lustigsten finde, sind meistens nicht Comedyfilme. Also ich finde Horrorfilme oft sehr, sehr lustig.
Ich weiß nicht, Into the Woods oder so.
Also da sind so Szenen bei, da kann ich nicht einfach.
Kevin Lache Woods vielleicht.
The Grudge finde ich auch wahnsinnig lustig, wie dieses kleine Kind die Treppe runterläuft.
Der Exorzist ist für mich ein Comedy-Klassiker.
Aber ich habe mir tatsächlich letztens einen guten Tweet überlegt.
Und zwar, also hatten wir heute die, also ich drehe ja Comedy-Videos für YouTube. Und das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr mit meinem Schauspielerkollegen unterhalten, innerhalb der Szene. Und es war ein geskripteter Gag. Und dann die Leute, die in momentan vorbeigelaufen sind, haben gelacht und haben gesagt, der war gut. Und dann dachte ich mir, würde das eigentlich in ein Comedy-Sketch passen, dass wenn die Leute was Lustiges sagen, die Leute, die gerade vorbeilaufen, drüber lachen, ja eigentlich nicht, eigentlich, und dann bin ich zu folgendem Gedanken gekommen, eigentlich bilden Komödien die traurigsten Welten der Welt ab, weil niemand über die Witze lacht. Über die Witze, über die der Zuschauer lachen soll, lachen die Leute innerhalb der Komödie überhaupt nicht. Das heißt, sie müssen in den traurigsten und verstörendsten Welten spielen Komödien, weil niemand über die Witze lacht. Ja, das sind die Brüche, mit denen man spielt und so. Es ist auch wirklich so eine wahnsinnige Erkenntnis. Wenn man deine Gedanken, die du als wahnsinnige Erkenntnisse raushaust, auch immer auf die Kernaussage reduziert, kommt meistens auch nicht so. Aber also wenn man sagt jetzt, also wenn man jemanden befragen würde, die Welt, in der eine Komödie spielt, ist die eher lustig oder unlustig, würden die meisten sagen, eher lustig, aber ich dreh das Ganze um, ich sag nein, gerade Komödien spielen in der unlustigsten Realität, weil niemand über die Witze lacht. Du bist der Clown, der weint, wenn alle lachen. Das ist, glaube ich, so ein Spruch, den man irgendwann gesagt hat, der eigentlich genau das auch ausgesagt hat. Schon vor hundert Jahren. Tu mir leid. Nee, war eine gute Erkenntnis. Machen wir jetzt noch Sportkanal oder nicht? Also was in der nächsten Folge machen? Dann machen wir in der nächsten Runde Sportkanal und ja. Also heute war Folge 10 und in der nächsten Folge nehmen wir dann den einen Kommentar, den wir bekommen haben, mit euren Lieblingsstellen. Den haben wir noch aufgeschoben. Schieben wir auf. Und wir haben auch die Liste der Gründe, warum man aufschiebt, machen wir nächste Woche noch fertig.
Machen wir nächste Woche weiter.
Und wir wissen auch, ihr habt es auch aufgeschoben,
eure Aufgabe, die wir euch gegeben haben,
sucht eure Lieblingsstellen, nennt uns die.
Habt ihr auch aufgeschoben, ist okay.
Diese Folge habt ihr gelernt, zumindest zur Hälfte gelernt,
warum ihr das aufgeschoben habt.
In der nächsten Folge können wir das ja mal dann besprechen.
Ja.
Bis zum nächsten Mal, wir verabschieden uns ins Wochenende.
Das war Florentin Will, vielen Dank an Florentin Will.
Ja, und natürlich auch vielen herzlichen Dank an Stefan Titzel, der heute natürlich wieder eine gute Leistung
abgeriffen hat und natürlich könnt ihr ihm auch gut folgen auf Twitter,
hat er da richtig gute Sachen raus und ihr könnt ja mal so ein bisschen
ihn so ein bisschen beobachten, das wär's für mich.